[Musica]
Dormi nella pace celeste dormi nei jingle
bells jingle bells tintinnano fino in fondo oh
che divertimento è andare in una
slitta aperta con un cavallo
faresti meglio a stare attenta è meglio non piangere è meglio non fare il broncio Ti sto
dicendo perché Babbo Natale  sta arrivando il
tempo
sognando un bianco Natale proprio
come quelli che conoscevo
le cime degli alberi e i bambini
[musica]
le campane della slitta nella neve
tu stesso un buon piccolo Natale lascia che il
tuo cuore sia leggero d'ora in poi i tuoi
guai saranno fuori figlio oh  il
tempo fuori è spaventoso ma il
fuoco è così
e siccome nessun posto dove andare lascia che nevichi lascia
che nevichi, sta cominciando a somigliare molto
a Natale dove ovunque tu vada dai
un'occhiata alle cinque e dieci,
ascolta e ancora una volta con  bastoncini di zucchero
e argento landsat ballon santa baby
basta saltare lo zibellino sotto l'albero per
me è stato abbastanza oh brava ragazza santa baby
quindi sbrigati giù per il camino stasera jingle
bell jingle bell Jingle Bell Rock jingle
bells swing e jingle bells suonano
nevicando e soffiando  g i cespugli del divertimento
ora il jingle hop ha iniziato a dondolare
intorno all'albero di
Natale alla festa di Natale miss it'll ronzio dove
puoi vedere ogni coppia cerca di fermare
lui ha il periodo più bello
dell'anno con i bambini jingle Belling e
tutti  dicendoti di essere di buon umore
è il momento più bello di
sì Feliz Navidad Feliz Navidad Feliz
Navidad próspero in piedi lo scorso
Natale ti ho dato il mio cuore ma
la notte successiva da cui mi hai dato ti voglio solo
per me più di quanto
tu guadagni  il mio desiderio si avvera
[Musica]
per
Natale sei tu
[Musica]
ieri sera ci sono voluti kawaki nosin tutti i
kappa venduti migliorare i posti da conoscere
sembra che tutti ma io sia innamorato
Babbo Natale puoi sentirmi Babbo Natale dimmi se
sei davvero lì per  fammi
innamorare di nuovo se mi vuoi qui l'anno prossimo
Babbo Natale dimmi se davvero mi vuoi qui
dopo un cappellino e Buon Natale
Feliz Navidad non mi darà un pelo
Jordan